Now, let me be clear.
There has never been an option before me that called for troop deployments before 2010.
So, there has been no delay or denial of resources...
...necessary for the conduct of the war during this review period.
Instead, the review has allowed me to ask the hard questions...
...and to explore all the different options...
...along with my national security team,...
...our military and civilian leadership in Afghanistan, and our key partners.
And given the stakes involved, I owed the American people and our troops no less.
This review is now complete.
And as Commander in Chief,...
...I have determined that it is in our vital national interest...
...to send an additional 30,000 US troops to Afghanistan.
After 18 months, our troops will begin to come home.
These are the resources that we need to seize the initiative,...
...while building the Afghan capacity that can allow for a responsible transition...
...of our forces out of Afghanistan.
I do not make this decision lightly.